ah scar is it correct that you view
screenwriting almost like a math
equation you piece parts together what
is your process for screenwriting I am
the highest aggregate ha ha Jemison area
Navy Saddam I see a cutter and head on
Dartmouth and getting fat Henderson Anna
that had the most of him whether in you
to be a context creation a new ticket
for Angela resume again became man I
welcome and not for the god of it in
each place of khatola 1dc the
standardization means that the thing
that might interest you and that I will
explain to you is that when I start I am
writing without any kind of calculation
any kind of architectural overview the
been as a mere the shrinking mushroom
impose a little and we cannot a machine
and hit you over John McConnell talked
yesterday with recombinant I like see it
seems when you see the film that I've
begun with the puzzle pieces that I keep
moving around until I find the final
shape but it's truly the opposite party
Kim and Regina a very colossus
television enjoyed guitars issuing
economy that would it has here when a
tire issues of that puzzle ho and Rijo
tokoha
once I've written a first draft summary
it's only then that I begin to correct
and to change the puzzle pieces in a
conscious manner
young man I learn about a lot of Aminu
some about know everybody was they
enough meaning i right in the first
stage with my heart and the rest of it
with my mind
you have many people waiting for your
movies do you ever feel a pressure or
what are your thoughts on an audience
that can be fickle at times I know
you've said previously that awards
although they're nice and they're very
complimentary are not the only reason
that you make films how would you can
have them goes down community followed
by especially how much like Adam both
laugh on it and kind of monkeys that are
snobbish on about yep a TV station one
baby not as I've stated before these
events allow the audiences to become
more familiar with the language of my
films and for a greater number of them
to see myself modest really could do
style I mean Akira community moving on
mondo Gustav even and which are you
think that Bevan and caicos Ottawa know
do join cause you're not alone what I
don't like it that they should go see
the film to see mean more than to see
the film
and where it's strong and where it might
not be as good how do you feel about
your films being framed
in a cultural view instead of a mere
thought of just stories about
relationships about people so when you
make a movie from a Western standpoint
it's seen from a cultural view with some
sort of a statement when really it's
more about human beings interacting
imbecilic a Tamagotchis of association
or a venom okay meet Alicia Garima Salon
de yada duty as Dona lasting from even a
assembles point now she came in Cujo
softest with the Robot Chicken area
chipping Salinas off they pitched a
virus out of a collective analytical
Karamoja motion it really depends on the
viewer and what their preferences in
terms of what angle they look at the
films from
it's possible that some viewer and a
faraway City may see the film and no
cultural aspect is important to them
they just are interested in seeing these
characters and where they're going money
by Huntington created educational value
heroes pas des moines South Pacific a
visionary wish the mountains initially
together did however as this is a
realistic film it's made in a society
and the characteristics of that society
are reflected in and can be found in the
film I know as a teenager in the 80s you
were involved in a cinema society what
would you advise to a young Iranian
filmmaker today who wants to make movies
happy Shia as in duty calendar home
began on the situation work on a chunky
montañesa Paris at America on the
rational component but it cannot choose
Akiba to a cool intern I'm a communique
well well no hood organism should work
on understand way of him sort on a bat a
photo goes much further comment
I've always refrained from giving
specific advice to try and guide someone
because the advice could in fact lead
them the wrong way but the one thing I
can say is to tap into their unconscious
to make their films rather than their
conscious wine to start with how many
more salary was a German oh no huzzah go
home okay I got between us Peter
Cordero's mister for the Kooning she's
very - a skill that the model that
occurs in the gaming is repairable to
the time machine show develop to the
Amigo downloader tasuku's Aria we all
have this incredible wealth that our
unconscious and overtime it somehow
then veiled and sunk to some depth that
we can't access it but if we could
access it there's unexpected and
wonderful things they're going back to
those early days of the cinema society
what was your goal in terms of making
movies and I think it was an Eastern
European film you saw that really
changed things for you maybe but what
did you want to say with films or what
was your goal in making them choose a
most eligible to eventually make a mum
as who the scene stuff down Cygnus at me
when I'm that I got in columns and
degrees reason they gave hatch the colon
ding Shiva all the time what a nice tone
you know I don't mean to teach a lot of
things I again there's a number of
things the one thing is that I really
take great derive great pleasure from
filmmaking and if I were not able to do
this life would be difficult for me
she's a particular Mohan very retro
secure be sure I'm your pity Caliban
it's like a communique saw - androgynous
issues along with completing bizarre
erotic thing that Madame Argentina
versus asked as that man for something
solid Eisenhower for that we remember it
is quite when you go down go spoken on
the other thing that's important and
perhaps have become even more so
recently it's for me to address
questions I have in my films and then in
the course of the ensuing discussions
learn and grow
thank you you're welcome thank you